ya que en los últimos vídeos hemos
estado analizando este escenario en el
que hacemos un tiro libre y tal vez
anotamos una canasta o no pero la
probabilidad de anotar la canasta es de
70% y luego en otro vídeo calculemos
cuál es la probabilidad de hacer acá
anotaciones en n intentos en n tiros
libres o bueno también puede ser en seis
tiros libres estaría muy bien definir
una variable aleatoria utilizando este
escenario y es justo lo que vamos a
hacer y vamos a calcular su función de
masa de probabilidad que por cierto
adelantándome un poco te digo que va a
ser una variable aleatoria binomial así
es que definamos la variable aleatoria x
como el número de anotaciones en seis
tiros libres
número de anotaciones o canastas
hasta
en seis tiros libres en seis tiros
libres tiros libres
ok x lo que hace es contar de los seis
tiros libres cuántos fueron canastas y
vamos a suponer lo mismo que en el
primer vídeo de esta serie de vídeos
vamos a suponer que la probabilidad de
anotar un tiro libre es de 70% aunque y
así es que estamos suponiendo suponiendo
que tenemos una probabilidad de anotar
un tiro libre de 70%
y vamos a calcular cuál es la
probabilidad de que x tome cada uno de
los valores que puede llegar a tomar así
es que vamos a empezar por calcular cuál
es la probabilidad de que x sea igual a
0 porque aunque tengas un 70% de
probabilidad de anotar cada uno de los
seis tiros cuál es la probabilidad de
que no anotes ni un solo tiro y esto es
algo que seguramente lo puedes calcular
muy fácilmente utilizando simplemente el
sentido común y esta probabilidad pero
para ser consistentes con el resto de
las probabilidades que vamos a calcular
ahorita vamos a utilizar la fórmula que
desarrollamos en el vídeo pasado así es
que la probabilidad de que x sea igual a
cero
las combinaciones de stage en 0 las
combinaciones de 60 x 0.7 a la 0 x 0.3 a
las 6 y bueno me tomé la libertad de
calcular esto y si lo redondeamos a la
milésima más cercana y redondeamos al
tercer decimal esto es aproximadamente
0.001 así es que tenemos aproximadamente
una probabilidad de 0.1 por ciento de
fallar todos los tiros libres ahora cuál
es la probabilidad de que x sea igual a
1 pues estos son las combinaciones de 6
en 1 x 0.7 elevado a la 1 x 0.3 elevado
a las 5
y eso es aproximadamente 0.01 qué
1 % es 10 veces más probable que notes
una de las 6 canastas a que no anotes ni
una sola canasta pero bueno si seguimos
queremos calcular la probabilidad de que
x sea igual a 2 o sea que no tenemos dos
de los seis tiros libres y eso otra vez
son las combinaciones de seis en dos por
0.7 elevado a las 2 por 0.3 elevado a la
6 menos 24 y esto es justo lo que
calculamos en el primer vídeo de esta
serie cierto cuál es la probabilidad de
que no tenemos dos canastas en 6 tiros
libres y como vimos en este vídeo esto
es aproximadamente 0.6
6 % y aquí estoy redondeando estas
cantidades definitivamente puede sacar
una calculadora para calcular estas
cantidades y vas a obtener una respuesta
mucho más precisa pero para visualizar
esta función de masa de probabilidad de
esta variable aleatoria tener una buena
idea de cómo se distribuye la
probabilidad entre los posibles
resultados de esta variable aleatoria
estas probabilidades redondeadas son
suficientes y más fáciles de manejar
así es que continuamos sacando
probabilidades ahora vamos a ver cuál es
la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3
y eso por supuesto son las combinaciones
de 6 en 3 x 0.7 a la 3 x 0.3 a la 6
menos 3 que es otra vez 3 lo cual es
aproximadamente 0 punto 185 y recuerda
que estamos aproximando a la milésima
más cercana y esto es también
aproximadamente 18.5 por ciento y 18.5
por ciento ya no es una probabilidad tan
baja como éstas o sea ahora si ya sería
creíble que notaremos exactamente tres
de los seis tiros libres o sea todas
estas situaciones definitivamente pueden
pasar están dentro de lo posible pero x
igual a 3 ya tiene una probabilidad no
tan insignificante ya no es tan difícil
que suceda como en estos casos
ahora vamos con la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 4 y esto es por supuesto las
combinaciones de 6 en 4 x 0.7 elevado a
la 4 x 0.3 elevado a la 6 menos 4
elevado a las 2 que es aproximadamente y
aquí le estoy quitando bastante
precisión al redondear a la milésima más
cercana pero es aproximadamente cero
punto 324 lo cual es 32.4 por ciento
tenemos 32.4 por ciento de probabilidad
de hacer cuatro canastas en seis tiros
libres y ya nada más nos falta calcular
dos probabilidades que nos falta
calcular la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 5
las combinaciones de 6 en 5 x 0.7 a la
quinta potencia por 0.3 a la 6 menos 5 o
sea 1 que es aproximadamente 0.3 03 lo
cual es 30.3 por ciento
eso es interesante no bueno y finalmente
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 6 o sea que no tenemos todos los
tiros libres esto es igual a las
combinaciones de seis en seis por 0.7 a
las seis por 0.3 a la cero y bueno 0.3 a
la cero es un 1 las combinaciones de 6
en 6 es también uno así es que esta
probabilidad es simplemente 0.7 a las 6
es aproximadamente redondeado a la
milésima más cercana 0.118 osea 11.8 por
ciento y aquí hay algo bastante
interesante
seguramente recuerdas que cuando vimos
la distribución binomial era muy
simétrica o sea primero subimos y
subimos y subimos y a la mitad llegamos
al punto más alto pero empezábamos a
bajar y era más o menos como si
pusiéramos un espejo aquí a la mitad y
teníamos que esta probabilidad era igual
a esta de aquí y ésta era igual a esta y
así nos seguíamos y si nos fijamos en
estas probabilidades que acabamos de
calcular no tienen esa misma simetría y
bueno eso sucede porque ahora tenemos
una probabilidad bastante alta de anotar
antes cuando estábamos tirando una
moneda justa teníamos 50 por ciento de
probabilidad de sacar sol y 50% de sacar
águila
sin embargo aquí tenemos un 70 por
ciento de probabilidad
y eso provoca que sea más probable que
tengamos una mayor cantidad de
anotaciones sin embargo si nos ponemos a
calcular estos coeficientes binomial es
las combinaciones de seis en cada vamos
a ver que estos números de aquí sí
preservan esa simetría y que lo que hace
que las probabilidades ya no tengan esa
forma simétrica son estos valores de
aquí porque las combinaciones de seis en
cero son 1 al igual que las
combinaciones de seis en seis las
combinaciones de seis en uno son seis y
las combinaciones de seis en cinco son
seis las combinaciones de seis en dos
son 15 y las combinaciones de 6 en 4
también son 15 y finalmente las
combinaciones de 6 en 3 son 20 porque
entonces como puedes ver en estos
coeficientes si se preserva la simetría
sin embargo estas probabilidades tienen
estos pesos 0.7 y 0.3
hacen que se pierda la simetría y tiene
mucho sentido porque si es muy probable
anotar un tiro libre entonces es
bastante más probable anotar muchos de
los seis tiros libres que vamos a tirar
es mucho más probable que anotar
poquitos tiros libres si en lugar de
tener un 0.7 de probabilidad de anotar
un tiro libre tuviéramos 0.5 entonces
aquí veríamos la misma simetría que en
los primeros vídeos de la distribución
binomial pero bueno y otra cosa que
estaría súper interesante hace sería
graficar estas probabilidades y de hecho
te recomiendo que lo hagas toma todos
estos valores en el eje x y en el eje y
pon las probabilidades correspondientes
y así vas a tener la gráfica de la
función de masa de probabilidad de la
variable x aunque como lo hicimos al
inicio de esta serie que teníamos una
moneda justa y la variable x será la
cantidad de soles que salían en 5 gol
2 bueno aquí tenemos esta otra variable
aleatoria de x está por acá x es el
número de canastas en 6 tiros libres y
bueno aquí no la gráfica pero esta es la
función de masa de probabilidad de esta
variable aleatoria x gray estos son los
valores que puede llegar a tomar x x no
puede tomar el valor menos 115 ni 3.5 ni
pi ni cualquier otro número que no sean
estos 7 números de aquí y para cada uno
de esos valores que puede llegar a tomar
x tenemos aquí la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a ese valor
bueno redondeamos esas probabilidades
pero esto es justo la función de masa de
probabilidad de la variable x